Alright guys, so here is example number one you can see the marker structure is bullish right heavily bullish and we are going up not consolidating. Okay, so right here what we have is consecutive bearish candles before move to the upside that broke this structure. So this right here this whole area is my autoblock. So I'm going to patiently wait for price to come back into my autoblock.
When that happens I drop down to the 15 minute time frame and this last bearish candle is going to be an autoblock. I know this is a huge ass candle but this is how autoblocks works.
I mean you can take this as an autoblock as well but again you might miss out the trade and I don't want you to miss out the trade.
Okay, so if it's like this I recommend that you take your entry especially for this strategy by this last bearish candle before the move to the upside that broke the structure.
So you can see we have a change of detector here and change of detector here. So now I'm going to patiently wait for price to come back into my zone which is right here.
Put my stop somewhere around here around 25 pips and I go for one to two and I go back home.
So let's see how this plays out.
Okay, so here's the thing.
You're going to see that this happened. Our entry was between this right here. So,
yeah, so the price was here, right? So you could have entered here because the kill zone?
Yeah, it starts from here. So,
your entry would have been here and you would have like went for two ratio.
What simple is that? You don't want to like,
you know, use like one to three or one to four. Just go for one to two. It's best for your psychology guys.
Trust me when I say this because I've said this so many times in my videos where I force you guys to take one to two trades.
When you do that, guys, it just gives you this feeling of consistency, okay?
You win more, your psychology gets better and all.
So you can see that was a perfect trade. We waited for price to come back into our autoblock right here.
And before our autoblock, we had a market structure shift. Our entry was during the kills on ours.
Sorry, do the London session, I believe.
And you can see prices smashed to our take profit level, took out these equal highs.
And even took out this high here as well.
Let's see where price goes.
Yeah, so it keeps on going. So here was example number one. Let me give you guys another example.